[Music]
three
two one action welcome back to off the
record where we talk about
whatever we want and today we got mickey
back
i love it when you're here i like being
here
me too me too cue the flirt with nikki
now joe come on right
okay yeah i caught on it's like hella
early i know drink your coffee
you're supposed in the morning too
though huh you have to fart in the
morning too
you have to keep it going good morning
texas we did talk last night
being excited about me being here today
so we're ready so how's this going guys
i think it's great you live your life
we're not jealous
it's like that duplex fantasy we have
it's like
it's gonna happen oh i'm excited about
it we're doing well
good i think i think it's very
beneficial for both of us
right friends with benefits the benefit
of us working
right that's the benefit no
i see the benefit of us being together
is me being here
yeah and he's building what a tea house
thing in your
oh no so i have a tea i have a well we
have a different office that you haven't
seen yet
and then in that room in my office i
have like a
japanese tatami like separate
yeah and that bed is so comfortable too
because he has a whole ass i will find
out
because i'll be sleeping there by myself
like
because you're moving down here yeah
eventually are you moving l.a
eventually oh i didn't know that yeah
that's cool so cool
surprise eventually we have to say
eventually gotcha really for legal
reasons
ah really yes why yeah
we might i don't know i've been here
before we already know what's going on
we got it we got it going yeah we have a
thing too yeah
not quite this thing and we have a thing
to do yeah we totally have a thing
uh we don't have things yet because you
have a thing oh yeah we have a thing
and you have a hi hi i just came out
from the room last time i was inside the
tech room up the entire time so
true yeah wait were you ever
you sound like kenny right now why oh
cause i got a gig
working on a set like a serious one
where they have to test you every like
five days um
yesterday and i didn't i didn't want to
you know
be irresponsible and be like oh look i
got tested and i'm clear but i'm going
to
talk to a bunch of people yeah so
responsible
yeah like normally if we're here like
i'm like oh cool i'm just going to go
home and if i get sick i'm
getting myself sick and i'm not putting
others at risk you know yeah
so it's not a big deal anyone's ever
caught corona from here yet
because we all got it because we all
which one you [ __ ] query wow cause we
had it in february
people are getting it again i know it
doesn't make us immune
don't jinx us well you can't get it
because you already had it is what i'm
saying no but i'm saying people are
getting it twice
is that true we don't know anything i
want the plasma [ __ ] what's that one
i want that one the plasma [ __ ]
that's like to save your life right i
don't know yeah so you have like
antibodies and [ __ ]
yeah if they came out with a vaccine
today would you guys take it no no no
no i would out of all the people here
you yeah
why wouldn't you i know you're not an
anti-vaxxer but i thought
you would i mean conspiracies man come
on i do i second-guess government and
[ __ ] but
i don't second-guess stuff like that
like science
i got all my shots an average of five
years before a vaccine is truly
developed so they're gonna make one in a
couple of months and you ready for that
they can test it on me you're about to
have
scales you're gonna go say i'm like i'm
not the first adopter
to breathe under water my dad is kind of
cool i
my dad's a type 2 diabetic so i haven't
seen him in a year
oh so i just want to see my family
that's so sweet you
stupid ass that's a sentimental ass
no crying i mean but what you could do
is you could take the swab and make sure
that you're
like corona free and go see him yeah i
know but he
he he is in such a state where if if
anything
if i was like a flu like you went to the
gas station and you touched corona
exactly dude
it would be devastating so i would i
wouldn't even take that chance whereas
i've seen my
in-laws a couple times because there's
nobody with that society and you don't
care about them
that much no no they're my in-laws
exactly
so so even though so flu season is we're
like in the midst of flu season you're
still going to be precautious with
that as well because oh yeah yeah i just
saw casey last night i was like
hey flu season is coming up we i want us
to go back to how we were
in march and be extra paranoid because i
really do not want to
deal with getting sick or risk getting
anyone else that i'm involved with
sick march is torture you know how many
times you go to the grocery store
every two weeks and in those two weeks
we'd have to stock up like
[ __ ] tons of like fruit and vegetables
that would actually go to waste they'll
go to it you got a week and a half maybe
you know
just get instacart no they suck
they're terrible but i hate going to the
grocery store [ __ ]
getting the fruit the the fresh stuff
the fruits and the vegetables
we ordered it twice already and they
came like they gave us stuff that
you couldn't even eat it was all rotten
how about amazon fresh
today's episode brought to you by fresh
start
apparently how about amazon fresh i've
never tried it amazon fresh i haven't
i live in the middle of nowhere i don't
think i get that oh really why did you
guys do more freezer stuff
like freezer fruits freezer vegetables
natural
just kidding i love that [ __ ] is that
natural it was like
technically they're they're frozen at
the peak of freshness that's right
they have more vitamins they have more
vitamins
yes really they get more vitamins from
the frozen process because
because you get it like right when they
pick it like it freezes
the peak of it so when they go and they
harvest it then they're like okay
this is the best it's going to be yeah
we're going to freeze it now
so that's what do you think of that [ __ ]
i'm going to go to the hospital
it still [ __ ] got mold on it well i
know that doesn't suck i don't think
your freezer works
[Music]
not to break too hard but i'm getting a
new fridge today
wait i know that feeling does it have an
ice maker thingy there's an ice maker on
the door [ __ ]
yeah i [ __ ] made it dude that's how
you know you made it amazing when your
fridge
has water oh my god that's all i wanted
to do
the most powerful people on the earth
even a hundred years ago couldn't have
imagined this kind of [ __ ]
i have more power than they do i have
more convenience and luxury than they do
steve let me let me bring you down to
earth a little bit we have more power
than you
we want our refrigerator actually makes
our coffee i'm sorry
that's true if it made monster energy
drink then i would care
we have a keurig built into our how does
that like so you just put a keurig cup
in it
yeah and then it could heat up the water
yeah
what brand general electric yeah
i never heard of such things never i
know they have the ones that are clear
that you can see what's inside and then
you can actually
go on a computer like it's a computer
screen and it tells you
what you're missing what you need to be
stocked on that one is the one i want
and then they have the counter tops that
are like that in the cupboards or yeah
that's just bougie man
we have goals in life you wanted an ice
maker i wanted to tell me when i'm out
of
uh almond milk nah what
that's great we're gonna have it in our
home just get ready for it okay
let's go there you go you're going to be
like 15 g's on the fridge for this
bougie [ __ ]
no well she's buying it it's only three
no we're gonna get it indoors stop it we
don't buy things
we're gonna get it sponsored we're gonna
get the whole house sponsored
remember the benefit that's the benefit
that's the worst is when i find out i
have to buy something i don't want
and i'm like all right honey yeah like
what just anytime we buy almost anything
like even when it was her decision yeah
well she's usually does
all the research on it right and then
she's the financial manager of our
uh life yeah same here just my financial
managers because if i was to make
uh our financial decisions i would bet
everything on cryptocurrencies
that's true you would live in a sleeping
bag while you're a whole store
it was a cryptocurrency yeah and i would
do well but
man it's not a good life yeah you'll
finally get your wealth when you're 80
years old exactly right
and then you'll be like see i told you
you're living the same way except you
wouldn't be investing anywhere we'd just
be living in sleeping bags
genius sleeping bags are great what's
wrong with sleeping bags so yeah so
anytime
we're buying something i'm like yeah
it's not that fun but
you feel like it could have gotten to
bitcoin yeah exactly
oh is that what it is yeah you just
don't like spending on on things
that make your life better i like buying
things that are gonna pay off for me
later
like an ice machine and sometimes much
later yeah yeah like a fridge with the
water in the ice
[ __ ] you that i'm excited about i want a
new washer and dryer
that's going to be my my big girl
purchase because
mine does not grow up thing i want like
i've never wanted one i
want one you want it when you realize
that you suck at doing laundry
and then it's like oh it was never
really me the washer
was not good what do upgraded machines
do that's different
i don't know okay they have music they
cost more money they
would have yeah oh it has wi-fi yeah you
could start it
from your phone but you still
they have like smart technology to
detect things you're like i know
my domestic duties i am not very good at
doing laundry so i'm just gonna lean on
technology to help
me that's okay we'll get like help and
technology
yeah we we're going to need a lot i need
a clothes sorting machine
when do when do they come out yeah they
have a
cloth i saw a closet thing no but
folding though i need to fold it
i'm telling you that it folds it and it
sorts it
out you pour it in how come we don't
have one like this
because it's not worth it why am i doing
this
[Laughter]
switch up maybe not 50 50. i feel like i
do it maybe like
20 percent of the times it's just 20
percent too much good 20
good good number casey got halfway
through that segment and he was like
wait a minute he was like this is
not gonna go over like ah let me
backtrack here
i do the laundry most of the time maybe
you do it like out of the fight would
you agree with twenty percent
probably or maybe less okay would you
agree with fifteen percent
i think ten to nineteen i'll give you
fifteen
will you take 15 all right it's 15 too
much
okay much are you doing laundry
absolutely not i won't touch it no
no i won't do it i don't know but last
time i went over there you were doing
laundry for the kitties i think
how do you do laundry for the cat so
they uh we have we're fostering kittens
right now and they were [ __ ] and
pissing all over the blankets and [ __ ]
so i
had to decide i have to keep cycling
them in and out yeah i do laundry all
the time i
i love doing all that is in his office
so of course he does oh it has to be
your duty it's in your
jurisdiction dude when laundry's on all
day i
just all i hear is like the inside of a
wind tunnel it's like
i don't mind sorting i just hate folding
i
hate folding with a god there's clothes
on my floor right now i only like to
fold when the clothes are fresh
after that it's like i gotta wash it
again i gotta be in a zone
i gotta be like we're cleaning today i
gotta be listening to something or
something yeah yes and it's just me so i
can't be like oh
babe go do the laundry it's more like
i gotta go clean it up myself i got the
hand this time you got it yep
come over you're like folding it that's
solved no but i got into design well
i also know that if i um
want to i could just drop off my clothes
down the street
at a wash and fold oh yeah it's like a
lot more i've heard of those places yeah
i mean well they do it at the cleaners
um like the dry cleaners or whatever you
just go and say i got this bag
okay 20 bucks and then you yeah a lot of
services where they pick up the clothes
from your house and they deliver it
folded already and then touching your
private underwears good
true i feel bad for them i feel like i
should pay more i'm like yo i sweated in
that [ __ ] so hard thank you
but you know you can always sell those
online because there's somebody that
definitely wants to touch you you can't
you can i can i don't think a lot of us
can i offer
there has to be yeah there are girls
that like love underarm like guy
smelling guys underarms and stuff like
really yeah
really are you one of those girls well
remember i used to keep one of your old
shirt or like your shirt that you left
at my house when i first started dating
this time yeah yeah no i loved his
armpit smell though
did you go like this
if i start a business selling used guy
shirts and doesn't work out that's on
you guys
there has to be meaning behind it i
think there has to be a storyline you
know women like
more to it has to be like he is going
away
for his career and won't be back for a
couple of weeks like you got to give it
some background
shirts with a story on it
yeah like how they sell those dolls that
have a background yeah
that's really cool i see your brain
working right now boyfriend thingies too
remember like those pillows that you
know yeah like a boyfriend like hugging
you oh yeah that was so sad
i'm telling you you could partner up
with those people all right
your shirts with that that's really good
because then there's a smell to it to
the sadness as well
yeah we could call it lonelytimes.com
what's the last fun thing you bought oh
man i'm decorating my room right now
so i was having fun going to ikea like
all this stuff i have my buddy helping
me out
it's gonna be really [ __ ] sick what
is it like going to ikea during a
pandemic right now
empty and there's not a lot of things
well not a lot of things are out of
stock because it's just taking a long
time to get things in so like you find
something
and you're like oh yeah i'll be there
next month next month what the [ __ ]
yeah who knows what next month brings we
don't know it i know
you don't know we can't plan ahead the
pandemics are supposed to be over by now
like like back in march we're like yeah
before the year
ends it'll be back to normal we're like
what are you guys going to do for the 15
days man
yeah exactly we were so naive back then
now this is the new normal mm-hmm i
don't know yeah
they're saying it's gonna last like way
like even if the pandemic
is done like the what we do with masks
and like social distancing
all that stuff is going to stay so
anywhere ahead we're heading for a third
wave or something wait what was the
second i don't think we've ever left the
first wave
i think other countries hit the second
wave we just have a long well you know
how in japan they've
been wearing the mask yeah that's
something that came from the spanish flu
that they kept
so before that they weren't you know
wearing surgical masks everywhere
they just decided to keep doing it if
they got sick
which is i feel like the only time i
care about it and i know this sounds
really selfish is when i'm wearing
makeup and i wish there was something
just a little bit further out that can
still protect me
but at this point i've traveled with the
mask been on a flight with the mask
you know been around family with the
mass to where if you find one that fits
and it works you
kind of just get used to it there's no
mass brackets i'm wearing one right now
everything away from me oh really yeah i
wanted to see
yeah oh i look like a cut i noticed that
under your mask i was gonna buy to ask
you too
because his mom sent me a video of like
someone promoting it or whatever and i
was like dude i want to do
you buy a kid yeah yeah yeah so like you
know how like sometimes mask will like
when it loses its shape it goes against
your nostrils
[Laughter]
yeah no but it makes it way easier if
you're gonna wear all day long it makes
it work but you're so
you're so excited to take it off later
because like that's so annoying
i hit one of those days where i was like
oh my god i need to take this mask off
i hit one of those we were in reno for
um because the casinos are open in reno
and my dad wanted to go to reno for his
birthday so i was like okay we're gonna
go
whatever it's kind of one of those
things like what can we do is gonna make
everybody happy cool we'll be safe
whatever so we went to reno and you know
we're in the mass the whole time
gambling and whatnot
but let me tell you all of us when we
got back to the room we're like oh my
god
first off i don't even know how we were
breathing in all that cigarette smoke
before without the mask i was like
i felt oh i feel a little bit better
because now i'm not inhaling everybody's
cigarettes and then as soon as it came
off it was like
give me all the air i could possibly
because now it got trapped in the mask
it's rough fresh air is nice that was me
leaving costco because i was in like an
hour line
oh and then without getting out isn't it
hot it's hot as [ __ ]
is everything as [ __ ] it's hot there why
where's the ac
do they have ac i don't know if it was
working very well normally you've got to
go to the refrigeration
room yeah that's it's ice cold man
i love that spot yeah they just have
fans going because it's such a gigantic
warehouse how is costco please tell me
it's more empty
it was full as [ __ ] when i was there i
think you know what i think happened is
because i had the idea too i was like oh
i'm gonna go stock up on [ __ ] before we
get a second wave or whatever the [ __ ]
i'll have toilet paper this time and
everyone had the same idea yeah
it is like a paper yeah flu season
i bet you even if we were um like clear
away from it
because of the election they're going to
keep it going uh
keep on going quarantine but we're
it depends on where you are because
finally where i'm at they just broke
into the phase where
now they're letting people in gyms just
reopen salons but every county is
different yeah so that's the only thing
is that
no matter what happens with the election
it depends on who's running your county
true because where i live versus san
francisco
san francisco's been closed but then
they ended up reopening before we did
so like stanislaus county in san joaquin
county is always like at the end of the
list
when it comes to stuff so you can eat at
restaurants in san francisco now yeah
you could go like you could go to the
gym but it how weird is that
i can go and drive 30 minutes to go be
in a restaurant but i can't
do that 30 minutes away from here but
everybody commutes
how much sense does this actually make
right it's like here in oc
you get shame for wearing a mask in la
you get shame for not wearing a mask
they still do that they still shaming
people for wearing masks
they look at you weird yeah beach cities
they're ugly that's why they look at
everybody weird
beach people are an interesting people
if you're if you're really staring
if you're mugging somebody because
they're wearing a mask you don't know
their life story [ __ ] it's not making it
something that it don't gotta be what if
this area just ain't right and that's
why they have the mask on
a lot of people do look better nowadays
oh yeah all of the all of this area
yeah it's made me realize people the
mouth area is not uh the place where you
find the beauty of people like this is
this is where people are beautiful
have you seen this and go actually
talk about that last time i was here
what you call it uh
yes nadeem talked about he saw some girl
and she was cute
and then she took off the mask and you
saw her on instagram and was no longer
interested yep
he was vibing with this girl the whole
thing but he's also extremely picky too
i mean again picky is fine i guess
he was vibing he was like she was super
dope and then saw her instagram was like
her mouth wasn't building her mouth
at least he's not running around saying
what that mouth do the jawline gives a
lot of definition
into like someone's whole face you know
how much lip filler would have
not been put in people's faces if these
masks were implemented sooner that's
true
are you speaking to someone particularly
no okay just in general i mean i have no
shame in that community i'm like
trust me all my friends everybody got
something in their face i ain't worried
about it
that's why i didn't realize i don't want
to get lip fillers do you never have
gotten it
but i don't know you don't need it
chicks don't talk about this at all
ever like especially when i'm around so
i never knew that everyone gets work
done
especially in la i'm sorry you didn't
know i had no idea
because nobody's talking like chicks
aren't like talking about it all the
time yeah well you must not be on
instagram
not lurking on girls pages no no exactly
that's very smart i forgot
smart man yeah there's well there's the
shaming side of it there's the oh
i'm all natural i would never do
anything to my face
normally the ones shaming anybody that
had work done had a lot of work yep
before and afters are crazy and you know
what if it's going to make you feel
better i think some people take it very
extreme and don't work on the inside but
sometimes that helps
some people's insights they become a lot
more confident and they feel better
if we have the technology why not i'm
very much into skin care like i've had
micro needling i used to have acne so i
used to have scarring
what's micro needling so they numb your
well micro needling with prp so
i go to this place called art of beauty
in danville and what they do is they
take your blood out they separate the
prp which is the rich plasma platelets
and they separate it from your blood
then what they do is numb your face and
they put
micro uh like needles like holes into
your skin which is punctured
just think of it a lot think of more
like a tattoo gun oh okay okay so think
of a tattoo gun going across and so it's
creating
so what it's doing it's injuring the
skin which is going to put collagen and
all that other stuff back there and then
they're taking your rich plasma
platelets
because it's supposed to be really
healing into the skin so it's supposed
to help boost collagen
remove acne scarring and that's the type
of work that
a lot of actors and actresses do is that
the vampire facial
yes but it's like but that's i mean they
just coined that that i guess that's
something else but the prp they put it
in your face
it honestly if you go and invest in your
skin like there's nothing better than
not wearing makeup for me like i think
that's like the best i don't like makeup
either
a lot of guys don't a lot of guys don't
like makeup but they also don't even
know the difference too heavy for him
it makes his eyes droop so if you were
on true if you were on set somewhere
and they were like okay we're gonna
touch up the skin are you like oh my god
no
are you gonna be like i mean like oh if
it's for work yeah i mean i put on
what do you call the the butterfly eyes
you put lashes on lashes
yeah yeah before because we had to do
all these characters and stuff
and then i was like so this i can't even
open up my eyes
you need to develop muscles to hold your
eyes up a lot of guys get skin work done
too there's absolutely nothing wrong
with it
nothing wrong i think it's great do what
makes you feel good you go to the gym
you go to the dentist take care of your
teeth take care of your skin yeah
i want to try it just for fun i got a
place i
told you i take it i think my skin's
pretty off off the [ __ ] hook though
but i'll do it again you guys have like
a lot of men have really glowy skin like
you guys all glow
i got a dry ass skin i'm not drying a
skin
it doesn't really bro no you look good i
started changing my skincare
i actually do it now i wash my face and
i put
moisturizer on you got the k-pop uh
regimen going on
no no it's just like he washes his face
and he puts more
you just wash my face good job
[Music]
you